an historic trip into space will now
have to wait until
saturday bad weather as you know force a
postponement
yesterday's launch of a spacex rocket
carrying nasa astronauts
mark strassman is at the kennedy space
center mark i was watching they came so
close
good morning to you good morning to you
gail yes so close in fact it was 17
minutes 17 minutes before launch spacex
called it off the
rough rainy weather that had threatened
here all day violated the safety rules
at launch time
and so it was a no-go nasa astronauts
bob bankin and doug hurley had already
strapped into the crew dragon capsule
the fueling process was underway and
spectators including president trump
and vice president pence were watching
but those rolling storms proved to be
too much
at one point while the crew was in the
capsule an
area near the kennedy space center was
under a tornado warning
spacex is trying to make history
becoming the first company
to launch people into space but open a
new era commercializing space
and letting companies become space taxis
for nasa
and other customers this mission would
take two nasa astronauts all the way to
the international space station
banking and hurley would stay there at
least six weeks these guys are both
space
veterans spacex has revolutionized
rocketry its falcon 9 rocket is reusable
and that slashes costs
and makes launches so much more
affordable its crude capsule is full of
2020 technology
and has been compared to a flying iphone
but no one not spacex not nasa can
control the weather
and safety of course is priority one so
this weekend they're going to try all
over again
first on saturday afternoon and if that
doesn't work on sunday afternoon
here is the bad news though tony both
days right now at least
only a 40 percent positive chance for
the weather
at least we get two shots on it though
mark thank you very much